accrochezv pour la discrétion les
enfants tu sais je croyais qu'avec la
fin de la guerre on aurait plus à
pleurer la perte de nos frères mais
c'était une erreur hors de question que
j'arrête de me battre et surtout avec
l'Empire qui pourchasse la
petite mettezla en
cellule Oméga attend depuis trop
longtemps qu'on la tire de sa
prison notre
mission n'est pas encore
finie rien n'est plus important que de
mettre en uvre la sauvearde garde de
l'avenir de cet
empire tout ce qu'il vous faudra pour
atteindre ce
but vous sera
accordé ils sont en
chemin et ils vous auront
tous on va passer tout ça sans même s'en
rendre
compte
tout le monde a couvert on n'est pas
très doué pour suivre les
ordres je n'avais pas l'intention de
vous tuer mais vous allez finir par me
tenter